what's going on everybody welcome to
part 25 of the intermediate Python
tutorial series in this video we're
gonna be talking about our args and
kwargs chances are by this time you've
probably seen them and if you don't know
what they are they're actually super
useful to use in to actually make your
programs a lot more dynamic but if
you're not familiar with them looking at
programs that have them you might be
like what the heck am I looking at so
let's go ahead and get into it so for
the most part args and kwargs like you
can think of arts and kwargs kind of
like this I see them compared to like
lists and dictionaries and I'm gonna do
it but they aren't the same your your
your your your functions will not
function identically to as if they were
being passed lists in dictionaries but
you can kind of think of origin cards
like so so you might have like a
function of some kind and then you've
got your regular named arguments so blah
blah blah and then you've got these args
which usually you'll see an asterisk and
then args that's just a list of
arguments and just like a Python list it
can be as many items as you want
and then you've got quarks and kwargs
are like a dictionary and just again
like a dictionary it can have as many
things in the dictionary as you you want
okay so args and kwargs kind of function
like that these are our keyword
arguments that's the key W or K W args
keyword arguments then these are just
arguments and it can be a list of any
arguments but again it's not totally
like a list in dictionary but I suppose
it can be a useful way to think about it
sometimes so let's say you've got a
website we're gonna just kind of already
use really simple code here I'm not
going to implement this necessarily into
the blob class that we've been working
on in the series um so let's just take
like a really simple example let's say
you've got a blog and you've got blog
number one of course it's like I am so
awesome there's something like that most
likely is what you're talking about
and then blog too
people like cars so maybe you've got
like this car blog so no cars are cool
and then um maybe blog three is pictures
of your cats okay so is your blogs now
you might have even more blogs but for
now we're just gonna say you've got
three blogs but later on maybe you want
to have the ability to have even more
blogs because let's be honest you're so
awesome so so let's start with define
blog posts and if you wanted a function
that was gonna take all your blog posts
you might just use arcs like so and then
what we could say is for post in ours
let's just print the post so now we can
come over here and we does a blog posts
and let's say for now you just started
your blog you just have blog one I know
we wrote blog two and three already but
right now we just want to host blog
number one maybe we want to go back and
edit the cars and cat one so we're saved
and run that and what we get is just
that one blog I am so awesome now later
on you just say yeah I'm ready to
publish the other blog so blog to blog
three notice that we're just throwing
these in just like regular parameters
here like we're just stuffing them on in
there we just have the args like this
right so let's run it again and boom it
works it args lets you just throw in an
unlimited number of arguments crazy so
interestingly enough you actually can
pass a regular regular argh and we'll
just call this like the blog title
so we'll say my blog right and then
we'll do I hate to say blog title I
don't know will say site title just so
it's totally explicit what this is and
then we'll say title and then args so
now we'll just pass site title here
sure enough this was well I'm telling
you it's gonna work anyway
oh we never printed well it works no
syntax error but let's also do print
title there you go my blog and then you
got all the the you know blocks under
that so it's pretty nifty that you can
have a function that just looks like
this and Python just knows okay the
first parameter is going to be the title
after that all the other parameters are
actually just part of arcs okay and
that's it so now let's say you wanted to
have maybe you want to get basically the
variable name and the contents of that
variable well in that case you're
probably going to be using keyword
arguments kwargs will keep the title
there and then what we're gonna do is
for and in this case it'll be actually
the title okay we're getting ourselves
into trouble here we'll say a P title
for post title I guess we're now gonna
print a P title post okay and then let
clear clean this up now now we have it's
expecting key word arguments so quartz
and we also need two asterisks there
somebody who's Yellin at their screen I
know it anyway blog one now these are
key words so they're gonna have their
named or I guess I don't want to say
name two arguments but keyword arguments
that's the right word so blog one and in
fact actually what we can do let's just
take this cut paste comma here comma
here and let me just fix the alignment
no I guess we'll just do that okay
now save that run it
and we need items so it's like a
dictionary icon so I don't there we go
third time's a charm no problem anyway
you can see that that's how you can kind
of iterate through and you named
argument if you really need the names of
that argument but a lot of times you are
because you're gonna want to have those
values tied to something
so that's keyword arguments now what's
interesting with this is like for
example you could also tie in arms just
so we're totally clear you can a lot of
times you're going to see functions that
accept args and kwargs at the same time
so title we're trying to think of
something that we could have for args I
really don't know so I'm just gonna say
for our in our brains our I I'm sorry I
just can't think of anything great
suppose you can say 1 2 & 3 and we'll
just run that ok so just to see ok the
regular typical parameter passed then
args was handled as we would expect and
then keyword arguments were handled as
we would expect so ok now one more way
you can see artists and cords mostly
you'll see this probably with args is in
the following kind of situation so maybe
rather than seeing it this way where in
this case we actually defined args and
kwargs in the function and then when we
actually called the function to happen
we passed regular variables which really
just looked like ok these are regular
all of these are just typical and these
were just named parameters that maybe
had some default values or something
like that or just trying to be explicit
because the actual value that we're
passing here we might we don't know what
that is so if we're going to look back
at our code later on it's helpful to
name some variables just so you know
what these random numbers are like one
two and three what are those what are
those numbers right whereas here we know
this is blog one two three and so on
anyway let me
where's gonna delete that and let's say
instead now you actually have let's do
lips
let's do define a graph operation and a
graph operation takes X's and Y's now
let's just go ahead and create just in
case someone doesn't have matplotlib you
could say this is a function that graphs
and and then X Y so that will print out
basically something that graphs these
things so now let's say you have x
equals one two and three and then you're
going to have a Y that equals to 3 and a
1 now what you could say is print let's
say or actually we don't need to prints
we're creating in that so let's just
call graph operation X Y I can't want to
say let's call it x1 and y1 just so
we're really explicit and what we're
passing here so let's say we run that
and sure enough that that works totally
fine and if you don't have matplotlib
don't worry about it but I'm gonna go
ahead and import matplotlib dot type
plot as blt and I'll keep that printing
and if you don't have matplotlib that's
totally fine just keep it printing I'm
gonna print X Y PT - oh okay and we'll
get a graph ok great so graph as
expected now what's interesting though
is actually what we can say is something
like this or you could say graph me
equalled x1 y1 and now graph me is a
list and in graph operation we can
actually say rather than passing x1 and
y1 I just want to pass some arguments
and those arguments are
me now again in the definition of this
function we did not say this takes args
we said these are the two arguments we
want to take it's not some unlimited
number these are the exact arguments so
what we can do here is run it though and
we see we get the exact same output
everything works as intended so this is
yet another way that you can actually
use the args I'm not entirely certain I
would recommend you do this all of the
time but I have seen people do it
because you can do it and a lot of times
if you're like writing out the same
thing over and over and a bunch of
functions like the same list of
parameters this can be like an easy way
to stop doing that but for the most part
this is not explicit so if someone sees
that okay we're running graph operation
and then we're running these are just
what are these ours they gotta like go
back and stuff but just know it's
possible and you might see it so anyways
that's it on args and kwargs
if you have any questions comments
concerns if you've got something cool
you want to show us leave it below
otherwise I'll see you in another
tutorial